the trial is over but clearly amber
heard is not done talking welcome to
entertainment tonight michelle turner is
off amber called her relationship with
johnny depp toxic with allegations of
drugs alcohol abuse and self-harm now
amber is doubling down on her testimony
and defending her truth all over again
in the closing arguments the depth
lawyers called your testimony the
performance of a lifetime i just want
johnny to leave me alone says the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
i'm the performer do you stand by
your testimony and your accusations
against johnny depp about abuse of
course to my dying day will stand by
every word of my testimony
johnny whacks me in the face he says
doesn't never hit you
he never is that a lie yes it is
amber blasted johnny again saying she
stands by her claim that he abused her
you know i made a lot of mistakes
a lot of mistakes
but i've always told the truth the truth
is the word yes and that was the issue
and that's all i spoke
and i spoke it to power and i paid the
price
the price while amber was ordered to pay
johnny 10.35 million dollars in damages
after losing the defamation case but
after doubling down on the today show
this morning there's speculation that
johnny could sue her again there is
always a concern that she could go over
the line and get herself in trouble yet
again
legal expert julie rendellman says
another depth lawsuit is possible but
not likely number one amber heard has
already indicated she can't pay
for the defamation verdict she already
lost is she able to pay a 10.4 million
dollar judgment oh no absolutely not and
more importantly i think johnny depp
recognizes the jury has spoken in his
favor and the court of public opinion
supports him
amber's team is planning an appeal the
today show will air more of her sit down
tomorrow and friday night it will be
featured on a special date line i would
not blame the average person for looking
at this and how it's been covered and
not think that it is hollywood brats
that they're at their worst
i
did do and say horrible regrettable
things throughout my relationship and it
was ugly
and could be very beautiful
it was very very toxic
we were awful to each other
[Music]
you